avant tout l'adhésion un programme nous
avons constitué une liste faite de
majoritairement de gens qui ne sont
issus d'aucun parti politique bien sûr
c'est une liste de gauche et écologistes
avec des gens d'europe écologie les
verts du parti communiste du parti
socialiste de génération et je tiens
d'ailleurs à les remercier et je crois
que les veaux et les allées aux hellènes
ont bien compris que grâce à cette
équipe soudée dynamique et compétente
nous allions pouvoir mettre en place le
programme que nous avons construit avec
eux d'ailleurs autour de la solidarité
autour de la démocratie et autour de la
transition écologique